Optimal,
minimal.
At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
You posted a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by zip recruiter.
You may have heard them everywhere.
They're growing like crazy.
They're an innovative platform for doing several things,
but especially improving the hiring process,
making it slick and elegant and easy.
One of the hardest parts of running any business,
growing any business is finding and hiring the right team.
I've seen this firsthand in close to a hundred startups now,
God,
I'm getting old from all over the world at different stages of growth and
nothing can quite drain your resources and cost you time and money like making
mistakes in hiring.
Ziprecruiter developed their own system and their own platform for helping you
to solve two of the biggest problems and bottlenecks for employers,
posting jobs easily and then making it even easier to find the best candidates.
Unlike other job sites,
ZipRecruiter does in effect the opposite of what you'd expect.
So they do not depend on candidates finding you there.
Technology finds the right candidate for you,
and in fact,
more than 80% of the jobs posted on ZipRecruiter return a qualified candidate
based on your criteria that you select in just 24 hours.
So no more juggling email,
reviewing hundreds of unqualified candidates.
I've been there,
done that.
Don't recommend it or dealing with calls to the office,
et Cetera.
None of that.
Simply screen rate and manage your candidates all in one place on Ziprecruiter's
dashboard and as a listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
thanks for that.
Ziprecruiter wants to allow you to start posting jobs and trying their services
for free.
So if you're thinking of hiring somebody,
you need to find any and executive assistant you need to find a developer,
whatever it might be tried out.
Just visit zip recruiter.com forward slash Tim and you can experience just how
ZipRecruiter has been used by businesses of all different sizes to find the most
qualified job candidates.
Again,
that's ziprecruiter.com forward slash.
Tim,
check it out.
Give it a spin.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many,
many years.
It comes with me everywhere on my telephone and my pocket.
I love audio books and they are one of my favorite ways to pass the time.
More than that,
to indulge myself,
to educate myself with time that would otherwise go to waste in some respects
when I'm taking walks,
when I'm cooking,
cleaning up the house on the road for travel,
whatever,
and those in between or as a secondary activity.
I love using audible to help me transform my downtime in a way.
And it's allowed me to consume more books,
many more books than I would otherwise.
You can access an unbeatable selection of bestsellers,
mysteries,
thrillers,
and anything you could possibly imagine really I've two to recommend right off
the bat one.
Uh,
and they recommended this even for nonfiction purists.
This is a fiction book ready player,
one by Ernest Cline,
alright,
that's read by Wil Wheaton Ready Player,
one buyer in his client,
check it out.
The reviews are bonkers and this has a cult following.
Check it out.
And then very selfishly,
I'll mention one that I put together with one of you guys with actually a
listener of the podcast who is also a huge fan of Seneca.
So the book is Tao of Seneca Tao,
Tao of Seneca,
s,
e n,
e,
c,
a subtitle,
practical letters from a stoic master.
And this is effectively an introduction to what I view as the ultimate operating
system for thriving in high stress environments.
That is stoicism.
It's become very popular among top athletic coaches,
CEOs,
a faster growing companies.
So checking out that is for nonfiction,
folks who must read or listen to nonfiction Tao of Seneca,
practical letters from a stoic master.
And as a listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
you have access to a 30 day trial and your first audio book is freak.
So why not go grab one of those ready player one or town of Seneca,
go to audible.com forward slash Tim to start downloading now.
Membership includes one free audio book every month,
exclusive sales such as 30% off,
all regularly priced audio books.
And unlike streaming,
you own your books once they have been downloaded.
And I like to listen oftentimes when I'm offline.
So you have that benefit as well.
You can't make more time folks just not manufacturing anymore.
It's out of print.
Uh,
you can't make more time,
but you can make the most of it a turn your travel,
commute,
dog walk,
whatever into something more with a free trial at audible,
audible.com forward slash Tim to learn more and start now.
Hello boys and girls.
Sasquatch is and squirrels if that's a thing.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show and I am sitting listening to
people whack myths and banana bags.
I'm imagining doing Moy Tai while I have positioned myself in what's known as
the cat room with red padding over all the walls at on its headquarters here in
Austin,
Texas.
Check out on it.
Oh and then [inaudible] dot com not a paid mentioned.
Just a thank you and hat tip to Mister Aubrey.
Thank you sir for lending me your space for recording.
This episode is a much requested follow up with Esther Perel at [inaudible] pro
e s t h e r p e r e l on tweak [inaudible] who has been called the most
important game changer in sexuality and relational health since Doctor Ruth and
since I first met as there I've spent more and more time with her and the more
time I spend with her the more impressed I am.
She is the real deal and very,
very insightful.
Her Ted talks on maintaining desire and rethinking infidelity have at this point
probably more than 20 million views and she's both seen and tested everything
imaginable firsthand with couples in 34 years of running her private therapy
practice in New York City as is the author of the international bestseller
mating in captivity.
You've probably heard of it,
which has been translated into 26 languages.
She is fluent in nine of those languages.
I've heard her in person use them and as Belgian native she now brings her
multicultural pulse to a new book which I highly recommend checking out the
state of affairs,
subtitle,
rethinking infidelity.
Her creative energy is currently also focused on,
uh,
the creation and hosting of an audible original audio series.
We or should we begin?
But the state of affairs is worth checking out in this episode as their answers
your most upvoted questions,
including how to foster relationship or marriage longevity,
the most effective ways to improve communication in relationships,
how to deal with criticism,
letting go of emotional baggage from past relationships,
how to know when to move on from a relationship that just doesn't seem to be
working and much,
much more if you like s three or you're going to love this and her episode is
one of the most downloaded of all time previously.
So here is more of the good stuff.
Please enjoy this wildly interesting in my opinion,
Q and a from your questions with Esther Perel.
Hi,
thanks for sending in your questions and let's dive in.
So this is a question from Gregoire briefly via Facebook.
The guts to ask her how to foster marriage longevity and he exercises with teens
or habit would be great,
especially around fostering deeper emotional relationships.
There is the first basics,
appreciation to simply seeing a lot of nice things,
not taking things for granted and not forgetting to say thank you and please
just because it's the person that you live with.
Making complements,
holding hands,
kissing,
stroking,
sending sweet notes,
buying flowers,
preparing breakfast,
bringing the coffee to bed,
all those sweet things that people do that basically let you know that you're,
that they live inside of you,
that you're thinking of them even when they're not there.
These daily appreciations do they go a long way and it's sometimes it's a real
diligent effort to keep doing them and then I am a strong fan of letter writing.
I think that when you fly away,
when you're away,
when you're sitting in a cafe,
when you just have a moment to drop a note that is not just on the birthdays and
on the anniversaries,
just kind of your,
your own musings about do about you'd,
you'd likes together your dreams,
where you're going,
how you met,
what you remember,
what you fancy.
That is actually very much the kind of the telling of the story.
You know,
the story of the couple there is a lot of intimacy in their touch is a major
experience of intimacy.
I think when you do that Uma and things that kind of really encouraged the other
person in which you recognize the material at their most authentic good,
do this thing.
This is really something you really like.
Take a few more days.
You know,
you want it to always take this class,
take this class kind of ways in which you encourage the other person to,
to be the best version of themselves and vice versa.
Be the best version of yourself with them.
It's really basic.
Uh,
what makes a relationship sustain itself and be um,
be more nurturing.
Next,
Alicia Behnia Eichelberger via Facebook asks how to lessen arguments in your
marriage.
Look,
I think it's all about the art of speaking and listening.
You know,
there was a,
a sculpture a few years back by Bruce Noman and it was a world peace project and
he had 23 inch monitors with faces of the most diverse group of people,
diverse races,
ethnicities,
gender,
ages,
all of it.
And every single person,
every face was saying,
I'll talk and you listen,
you talk and I'll listen.
They'll talk and we listen.
You talk and we listen.
And it just showed you this,
the,
the robustness of this most difficult arts,
which often I would say listening is harder than speaking.
But then for some people,
maybe speaking actually becomes the hardest thing in a relationship.
You can often get the daily hassles in which you are grinding at each other.
And um,
in which there's a friction going on.
Don't sweat the small things is probably really important in terms of,
uh,
um,
how people deal with the arguments in a relationship.
I would say,
don't complain,
ask behind every criticism.
There's often a wish.
And if,
because if you believe that your partner has done something wrong,
that they didn't pay a bill on time or anything,
um,
and you wish that they had done it right,
but instead of asking them to correct it,
you basically tell him that he can never do it.
Well that you,
they're doing this on purpose,
that,
you know,
just ask them to do it better next time,
rather than would it kill you,
you know,
something simply do you think that next time,
you could set a monthly alerts so that you don't forget,
it's a very different tone.
It's a very different way of relating to the person.
There is no contempt in that one,
which we know from the research of John Gutman is one of the four horses of
apocalypse.
Actually,
I'm going to give you the four horses get hit really important.
One is criticism,
contempt,
stonewalling and defensiveness.
Dose for a pretty much the,
the,
the killers in the,
in the land of arguments and relationship.
The client,
you know,
try not to talk with categorical of all,
always and never all or nothing.
Um,
that probably is one of the most important changes in vocabulary.
banish them.
You know,
I always have to ask you,
you never do this.
No.
But the moment you say you never deal,
the person's going to come up with the one time that they know and that they've
done it so that they can defeat your argument rather than really understand that
you're asking them to do it more often,
which is exactly why I see ask,
don't complain,
add some humor at some humor is nothing that's going to diffuse your arguments
more than just putting some perspective into it and not take yourself so
seriously.
So empathy at the end of the day,
you know,
as soon that you burn,
it has the same interest as you to solve the stresses in your relationship and
for that to happen.
It's one that both of you understand and appreciate the other person's point of
view.
Do you really think that the other person wants you to purposefully be annoyed
or hurt you or let you down?
Probably not.
Um,
it's all of that shift that takes you out of relationships that are mired in
bickering,
chronic low intensity warfare or high conflict because there's a range there.
Okay.
Imagine I asked you as you arguing,
turns toxic as in does burner keep telling you that you can never do it right or
that they can never do it right by you?
That every little convo about who should set the table will end up in a blowout
about how dysfunctional the relationship is or that two minutes,
eight minutes into a fight,
one of you is saying we should get a divorce or we should break up.
That's what I'm calling a high conflict couple.
The opposite of the arguments is you come in and you see,
I want to listen to what you have to say.
I want to apologize.
What can I do to make this better and not?
What can you do to make this better shifted around and you'll have magic
happening.
Okay.
Next question from Ben.
Ultimate about jealousy,
how the majority of nonexclusive relationships I've seen seem to get done in by
one of two parties feeling possessive.
How do we read ourselves from these negative emotions when I think that jealousy
is intrinsic to love,
I don't think of it as a negative emotion.
It is part and parcel of the experience.
I think that sometimes it's an interesting experience in particularly in the US
where people often will say,
I'm not jealous cause I'm angry as if jealousy is,
is a feeling that is politically incorrect.
It doesn't have much popularity these days.
Jealousy is an erotic rage.
Jealousy is the feeling you have when your partner takes their love,
their desire,
their excitement to someone else and you wanted more directed toward you,
it is toward away from you.
Um,
so I don't suggest that you read yourself from that emotion.
I suggest that you integrate the emotion.
It tells you something,
it,
it generates action.
It generates conversations and it is not the same as possessiveness.
They're related,
but they're not the same.
On the other end,
he was a simple formula for possessiveness.
If you love someone,
set them free.
If they love you,
they'll come back.
Joseph Dibella dope posted this question on Twitter is the,
what is the best way to move on after divorce and deal with post-marriage
depression,
sadness,
especially for men who find it difficult to speak about their inner pain of the
divorce.
And the lack of connection.
Joseph,
I'm going to tell you something.
Men have a much harder time post divorce emotionally and physically than women.
Maybe not financially,
but in every other respect they do.
Uh,
they suffer much more.
They're more at risk for accidents,
for drinking.
Uh,
they take a hit because they need women even though they want to pretend that
they don't.
Uh,
it goes against the cultural narrative.
I think that what you have in this moment is two things.
One,
you absolutely want to reach out,
and I think if you have friends that you can talk to,
that would be great.
Male or female friends.
If you want to go to a men's retreat to a men's group,
there is nothing comparable to it at this point.
Then groups where guys come together to talk about their inner life,
what's going on with them.
It's empowering.
It builds solidarity.
It takes you out of the loneliness of the shame out of the isolation,
out of the feeling of failure,
all of it,
all of it.
There's nothing more powerful than a group of people that come together and hold
one person,
well that person can't hold themselves.
It's a spiritual challenge.
It's not just a relationship challenge.
So you need to go get energy,
you're depleted and one of the ways that you get energy is by going to do
something for others.
Go help others.
The research is very clear.
The most powerful antidepressant is doing for other people.
It puts things in perspective.
It makes you feel like you have something to offer.
It makes you feel appreciated by the people whom you're helping.
It changes the entire equation of what's going on inside of you.
Um,
right.
I think journaling is an important part of morning.
On occasion,
if it works out,
it may be a good thing to have a final conversation with your eggs and bit of
time later where you kind of clear things and you try to have a different
conversation than the ones that you had when things really tanked.
I think that it's also useful on occasion to go to your family and to ask a bit,
little bit about what has been the history of relationships in the family so
that you get to get to learn a little bit as well.
Whereas some of the unknown legacies that you carry inside of you,
the main thing is don't isolate yourself.
That's,
that's it.
And you will see that when you start to,
people generally appreciate it,
the don't know to do it themselves,
but they like it when they feel that they have something to offer when they made
to feel significant because someone else opens up to them.
It's the opposite sometimes of what we anticipate.
Okay,
good luck to you.
The Real Josh Gil asks on Twitter,
I'd love to hear her talk about letting go,
moving past the anger from being cheated on the anger towards the partner that
cheated the friends that seemingly abandoned the one that was cheated on and the
anger towards the self for not seeing the relationship falling apart sooner and
trying to fix it.
A lot of self blame here,
right?
A lot of self blame and a lot of anger at the other people for not being there
for you.
You know,
often when people are cheated on Diff,
the first thing is to say,
what's,
what am I,
what's wrong with me?
What am I missing?
Why am I not enough?
Or why didn't I see it?
Um,
but sometimes there is a reason that people engage in trauma denial that people
don't want to see because when we don't see it protects us.
It preserves a certain coherence to our life.
Uh,
it's not just because we are fools and idiots and easily duped.
Um,
so be careful about not pouring all kinds of self loading onto you.
What kind of an idiot are you?
How could you not know it?
Uh,
what kind of a guy lets himself be walked on like this?
we,
you should have known,
you should have seen,
you should have done more.
Ask yourself this questions,
but from a place of responsibility,
not from a place of beating yourself down and blaming yourself because then you
can't think if you put yourselves that much done and you feel so terrible about
yourself,
you cannot really think or you can do is just protect yourself from getting the
blows.
Now there are phases in the recovery as well.
The first thing is just simply,
you know,
the hurt,
the anger,
the confusion,
the disbelief,
the disorientation,
the,
the loss of the predictable future,
the idea that whatever you thought your life was going to be,
it isn't going to happen.
All of that,
and you need to really respect that all the screenings are going to hit you all
at once and it's going to be an avalanche of all this Maelstrom.
And that's normal.
It's in the nature of the beast.
It's really,
really normal.
And gradually at the occasion you will mourn this and you will think,
you know,
it wasn't good anyway.
And at other times you will say,
I could have continued this way.
How could she destroy all of that?
And then you can ask your friends,
talk to them,
did you see things?
Did you try to warn me?
Did I not listen where you equally as surprised as me?
But you need to know that there are phases of recovery.
I've written about it extensively in my new book.
You go from the crisis and you go and you move into the insight phase where you
start to make sense of all of this.
Why did this happen?
What can I learn from this?
What does it say about our relationship?
What does it say about me?
What does it say about her?
And then there is the,
where does this take me now?
What am I lessons?
Um,
where am I going to go with that?
And,
uh,
and,
and try not to have this just become a script for anger and bitterness.
I think that when you're very angry all the time,
you basically also protect yourself from not being too sad,
from not being hurt.
From that feeling vulnerable,
um,
it kind of props you up to being angry and it gives you a sense of
righteousness.
But be behind the anger is often a real sense of collapse and let yourself go
there.
It's okay.
It really hurts to just be angry isn't going to make it for you.
And how to allow yourself that by being with people who you trust to with next
to whom you can fall apart,
who won't judge you for it,
who understand heartbreak.
It is a new human emotion.
It's one of the oldest experiences we've had and it's part of our humanity.
You want afforded,
you want,
avoided.
Let yourself feel the pain and the hurt and the sadness and cry and then you'll
come through it.
You know,
I'm thinking about the guy that I wrote about in my book who,
who's who was at,
actually,
it was his brother who cheated on him with,
with the girl that he used to date.
And uh,
for years,
every time a girl liked him,
he taught,
you know,
who's who,
who's health is hiding here behind that.
I'm not saying he really carried it with him for a long time.
It takes a while til you begin to trust again till you begin to feel good about
yourself again to the field that you are able to be loved and lovable.
It really goes very deep.
This experience.
Um,
it taps into our sense of self worth,
all of that.
Uh,
and I hope that the stories that I wrote about in the book will help you with
that.
Uh,
they were meant for that.
They were meant to help you.
Okay.
Thank you.
Ron.
Jannie 86 writes on Twitter.
Is it harder to find true love as you get older and progressively more
intelligent?
Do you have to be young and stupid to find love the most people in search of a
partner's settle at some point?
I'm glad you back,
but uh,
I'm going to challenge the premise of your question a little bit.
You know,
what does it mean that you're going to settle that you,
I think the main thing is this.
When you are younger,
you allow yourself the experience of meeting someone,
seeing where it takes you unfolding with the story and uh,
and embracing the,
the,
the surprise of where this thing is going that you didn't expect.
But when you're looking for in the relationship as an adult and you come with
your expectations,
you often toward the possibility for a story to unfold and to surprise you
because you're sitting there with an inventory and you're not really allowing
for the unknown to,
to open itself up to you and to take you on a ride that you didn't see coming.
Um,
I think most of the dating that involves a checklist is don't,
that's,
that's the best way I can say.
It's,
it's anti romance.
It's anti story and stories are the way we live our lives.
Um,
it's,
it's a list of items and often you will find that people match all the items on
your list and the feeling isn't there because the feeling is something that
emerges that develops through interaction,
through shared experience to the creation of a shared story together.
And,
um,
I don't believe that that is any less possible as an adult.
In fact,
when you are older,
you are clear about what you like,
what you resonate with,
you know yourself better.
And from that place you are more able to appreciate the person that is in front
of you.
But it's not like you have to be young and foolish to fall in love.
No,
absolutely not.
There is no wage for it.
People Fall in love at any age at this point.
People have the opportunity for the first time in history to actually start an
entire new lives,
um,
in their 50,
60,
seventies.
Um,
love doesn't have an age to it.
We love differently because we are more mature because we accept certain things
more.
And because we accept other things less,
and we don't necessarily call that settling.
Settling means what?
I only found six items on my list out of the 10.
That's not the way we do it.
We make a choice and the choice always involves a loss.
And at some points we make certain choices that are maybe more rational or more
forward looking.
We understand that there's certain things we need in order to live with someone
and that there are some people with whom we could have a fantastic lover,
fair and a fantastic adventure,
but maybe not necessarily build a whole life together.
And in that sense we become,
we are able to hold more elements at the same time and make a decision that
embraces ambivalence.
It's something that that I called maturity,
not settling.
Debbie,
Lina asks to Twitter,
when do you know a relationship is done?
That is such a powerful question.
It's really,
but uh,
but what do we mean by done that you don't like who you have become,
that you don't like what you're doing that you don't like,
how you,
how you're being reflected back that the relationship has lasted cell service.
It's sense of a lightness and vitality or that it has become toxic and is dying
on the vine.
What do we call done?
Yeah,
I think that the main element that is really for me the kiss of death,
the end of a relationship is contempt cause it's really involves a profound
sense of dehumanization.
When that tone that just says look at you,
come on.
What is this is that you call this a relationship,
that sense of this of self loading and contempt.
It's very hard to come back from that.
You can fight,
you can be critical,
you can complain,
you can be volatile,
you can have a lot of things in a relationship.
Um,
because from there you can always come back into suite repair,
tender connecting,
et cetera.
And you just go to the cycles of connection,
disconnection and repair,
which is the triad of relationships.
But contempt is a real tough one.
Um,
the belittling the infantilizing,
the,
the meaning,
the degrading,
all these categories of relationships,
which basically amount of abusiveness.
To me that is a moment where in a relationship really is done.
Because what it means is that one,
in order to protect oneself,
when needs to leave,
unless you're the one doing it,
and then in order to protect yourself in the other,
you need to change.
Thank you.
Kelsey.
Homan asks on Facebook,
how does she handle her critics?
Oh,
good.
That is a wonderful question.
Does she read and comment on the Internet trolls for her book reviews,
but cast et cetera.
How does she deal with the people who think they know more about relationship
than her?
So I love this question because it allows me to say something,
you know,
I am often considered a thought leader or an expert.
I actually see myself much more as a student and as a person who is avidly
curious and continues to learn on a daily basis rather than as someone who
positions herself as knowing.
I think about these things a lot.
I often can sound very confident,
but I'm sure of nothing.
And one thing I can say is that nothing I say is made up.
But that doesn't mean it's true.
I also don't think there is one truth and I think that I am a person who
continuously seeks to be challenged.
I go and then check with other people.
Am I missing something?
Is there something I didn't think about?
Is there validity in the criticism?
Um,
I invite conversation,
dialogue,
confrontation and disagreement where it hurts.
Where I find myself at a loss is when people are taking one thing.
I say completely distorting it,
character,
character cheering me or what I say when I try so hard to embrace complexity and
nuance and kind of feel completely flattened by a complete misunderstanding of
what I say often to the extent where I wonder if the people actually really read
my work,
engaged with me.
And I wish that the predicts actually came to me and asked me and engaged with
me and challenged me rather than just,
you know,
trashman I generally try not to read too much of it because it hurts and because
I don't feel that there is an invitation for the dialogue.
Uh,
whoever comes to me directly,
respectfully and says,
I disagree,
I think you're wrong,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I will speak with whoever is avoiding me and just going behind my back and using
the Internet to anonymously or not anonymously.
Uh,
trash.
Um,
I think is participating in the same culture and in the trash and culture of the
moment and with all the consequences that we all know are involved in this.
So that's my relationship to criticism.
I welcome it when it's done.
You mainly when it's done respectfully,
Seth frank one asks on Twitter,
we often hear communication is key in the relationship,
but as I believe she has mentioned in her book too much can hinder desire.
What then is the juice to Amelia?
Okay,
listen,
we make me think of a song by Carly Simon,
no secrets in which she has aligned sometimes.
I wish I didn't know those secrets of yours.
No,
I think that the free love of the 60s came with a view of honesty and
transparency and letting it all hang out there.
And while it kind of came with the rise of individualism has everything that a
person experiences is at the center,
it matters.
It needs to be met.
I also think that the other side of this kind of wholesale sharing is um,
and it does have candor like that is that there needs to be consideration,
politeness.
And I find that those two qualities are often in short supplies,
in contemporary relationships.
There's this notion that we expect the partner to just hold on to all of our
feelings and make us feel better rather than engage a little more in our own
self suiting and in our own self regulation and in going in venting to others.
It actually has always been the case that people vented to people outside of the
relationship in order to be able to sustain what happened on the inside.
But it's about kind of don't let your emotional hemorrhoids bleed like that
inside your house all the time.
I don't know that this is always the best.
We of course want communication,
we want exchange,
we want deepening and real meeting with the other,
but I'm not sure that the kind of all out there is the only model and what
you're going to hear from me always is that there isn't one way only there isn't
one size fits all.
And so while I answer you in one way,
I may answer someone else differently and I think it's that richness that I want
us all to hold here on occasion.
Let it be,
you don't have to react to everything.
Not everything is a tense.
Certain things are just too,
they're not really that important.
And that's another song that I think we really need to be able to hum on
occasion.
And in terms of the,
the,
the not telling everything on the desire,
it's really this,
the questions,
the interest that you want to keep for your partner or vice versa are a way in
which you remain curious,
interested,
engaged with the other person as a person.
The way that we often are in the beginning where we are just interested in who
is this person and what happens over time is that people often feel that they
know their partner as if they belonged to them as if they're just an extension
of them.
And that's an actually a contrived illusion of safety.
It's not true in the face of the unknown which exists right in our midst.
There is that mystery of the other and the mixture of the other is simply
available once you continue to be curious about them rather than assume this
kind of familiarity.
That's what I'm trying to say about the connection to desire because if desire
exists in that space of exploration,
of discovery,
of curiosity,
once you remain curious to your partner,
once you continue to think of them as a person,
not just as your partner,
the desire can continue to try it as well.
The next question you're asking is what according to her observations and
experience at the essential blocks to build a strong foundation between partners
and what is ascension in a relationship to maintaining longevity?
The many,
many pieces that I think a part of driving relationships,
but I'll give you a few,
just the ones that come up now and then if we meet again,
you'll ask me again and I'll give you a few others.
Yes,
I'll go on.
Number one,
not everything must be said.
I think that,
uh,
that in,
in light of the culture that we live in today,
I will probably say not everything must be said.
If we were talking and meeting in other parts of the word,
I would say the exact opposite.
More things need to be spoken sometimes.
Okay.
Just so you understand these things.
His answers are always taking place in a context and specifically in the
cultural context.
The second thing,
I think one of the most important it combinations in a relationship is the
combination between empathy and responsibility.
It's your ability to continue to see your partner and from their own point of
view is to enter the shoes of the other and on the other side your ability to
take responsibility for that which is yours,
your own contribution,
you mistakes.
If flaws just,
I'm sorry I did this,
actually I would,
next time I'll do differently.
I own it,
I own it.
The minute you can own something,
it gives you freedom rather than thinking that all problems in all changes
actually belonged to the other person.
And the next piece that is really essential to the balance to do in a
relationship is the ability to navigate separateness and togetherness.
You know,
to have space,
to have individuality,
to have self expression,
to have your own friends,
to have your own experiences that are not all related to the couple.
And then also to have some very strong things that belonged to the couple,
but some couples have a tiny overlap of the concentric circles and some couples
have a complete overlap.
So there's a range.
Some people love to just have a big,
big,
big togetherness and a small separateness and others the other way around.
But it is that negotiation and it changes over life.
It's not one in the same when you meet and then 15 years later,
the next thing for a long relationship is flexibility.
Adaptability.
It's your ability to say,
you know,
we used to do it like this,
this worked for 10 years.
It doesn't work anymore.
Change.
And that thinks that people are much more able to do in their companies and in
their workplaces than they are willing to do at home.
This is often a real static,
uh,
attitude towards the relationship.
We met a certain way,
we set it up a certain way,
my role,
your role,
my responsibilities.
You were supposed to be.
And it goes on like that for 35 years,
you know,
and then we collapse.
So the ability to just come together and say,
I need something different.
Let's change this.
I love couples who have an annual summit and kind of reviewed their
relationship.
Where's it going?
How are we doing?
You know,
or even monthly.
It just because it,
it shows intentionality.
It shows attention.
It shows care the same way that you water your plants,
you know,
uh,
rather than a kind of,
letting it go in this affair for,
for a long time on.
And um,
that kind of diligence makes a big difference.
And then the last one I will say for longevity and for trading relationships,
because so many of you had the question about what makes a relationship last is
engaging with new experiences,
not just comfortable and pleasant experiences.
Those,
those make for real familiarity and security and stability in the couple.
But what really makes a tribe,
what brings it a lightness and vitality is the engagement with new experiences
outside of the comfort zone because they breed new cells and all the research is
confirming that at this point I'm novelty breeds testosterone.
It's,
and it's not another to of sex,
sex positions.
It's really different ways of being with oneself in the relationship and with
each other.
So all of that combined.
You have a good chance to go for quite awhile.
Alex and daddy's phone,
Twitter and Aspen.
Jeannine will on Facebook are asking,
how do millennials bring back romance and emotional intimacy?
What do you see as the biggest flaws of young men in their twenties and how they
communicate with women?
What advice do you have for them?
I'm going to divide this into,
look,
there isn't much romance when people make date some texts all the time.
On occasion today,
Romance will be a phone call in the past romance.
Well,
the card,
it's like,
you know who still gets picked up at the door,
who still gets brought back at the door,
who gets them?
Of course the next morning.
I mean it's all these things that um,
are often seen as kind of pissy and an a,
an old century.
But in fact,
I don't think the repertoire has particularly changed it.
What the text doesn't go very far in terms of flattery,
does it anything that goes beyond the bare minimum is romance because romance is
pining romances,
seduction,
romances,
flirtation.
And that is a cultivated art by which you are gradually making the other person
melt in your arms.
But for that you have to be able to say,
I want you.
And that means you have to experience the vulnerability of putting yourself out
there.
And it seems that these days too many young people are quite reluctant to
experience the vulnerability and the uncertainty of not knowing,
of making that phone call and hoping that somebody is going to answer and it
won't be her dad,
you know,
like just to be an,
and that butterfly thing,
um,
has kind of been done away with the stuff is way too much immediate
gratification.
So there is no,
no space in between to seal experience.
The excitement and the anticipation and the uncertainty.
But all of that was part of romance.
That was the romantic plot,
romantic plot.
It plays itself out in the will it happen,
won't it happen?
The new Moisey relevant.
That's the,
you know,
a romance novel is 300 pages for the last piece.
And the last piece is the,
is only one page.
It's 300 pages of will though,
will it not?
And that's romance.
Now in terms of the question,
what to do,
take the risks,
the risks don't just go in a bar just to,
it's not just a booty call.
You know,
put yourself out there and say,
I want you to now take the time.
I coach this guy recently.
Um,
and it was very sweet.
You know,
woman basically calls it off seven o'clock,
Friday night,
you know,
not a very nice thing to do.
She's busy,
she has a meeting,
whatever.
And I'm,
and he goes into a whole,
you know,
should I wait,
does that mean she's not interested?
She's interested.
I just said,
look,
text her back and say,
I understand.
Makes you know,
you're uh,
but twice as much time for tomorrow.
Please come back with something that is funny.
But that breeds confidence and that is assertive and that says,
I'm very interested and,
uh,
you owe me a double dose.
Um,
she liked it.
She liked it.
No.
If she doesn't,
if she has no interest in him,
then she will tell him at that moment,
please don't bother.
But if she has a slight interest in him,
he will gain a lot of points with one of those things.
Um,
I've done more and more,
you know,
coaching people lately,
just looking at their Tinder feeds.
Just the kind of exchanges.
Uh,
not only do they like Romans,
they liked,
they like
anything that says to people,
you know,
you're interesting to me and I would like to meet you.
Just,
it's really thin.
It's really thick.
So,
um,
there is the issue of romance,
but there is the broader question simply of how do people these,
this literally,
um,
turn each other on with their minds,
not just the other ways.
Okay.
Um,
men,
there's a beautiful book by Rob Garfield called questioning the male code,
which I recommend for many of you.
Um,
but the mayor could often comes with a fix it attitude,
um,
and fix it is I have an answer.
I have a solution.
Uh,
and it is part of the making of masculinity competence,
performance,
problem solving.
So,
um,
unfortunately in the relationship with women fix it doesn't often work because
many times she wants to only talk and she wants to share the experience.
She doesn't really want to be told what to do.
She's quite competent.
She quite knows what to do.
And if you give her unsolicited advice,
she experienced it as patronizing.
So the flip side of fix it is empathy is two things.
Tell me more.
Men set the tone you need to do.
You don't have to solve it.
You just have to ask her if she wants to continue to talk about it and he wants
to engage in,
in patting murmurings Oh really?
Oh,
that's tough.
Oh Wow.
You know,
that can't,
um,
that says I'm listening.
It is most of the time what she needs,
if she want to give advice,
ask her if she wants to hear it and otherwise,
which in she asks for it.
The fear that people have sometimes that guys have,
when they said to me more is that she's going to study in it.
We never stopped saying,
if she says we have to talk,
he says how long?
And in fact when you say,
tell me more,
the answer will be much shorter than if you don't.
And she still isn't sure that you really get it.
So that's really the main,
the main piece in terms of uh,
men in communication and I'm not so sure that it is different for young guys or
for me,
even men,
my generation boomers,
it's really you don't have to have an answer and you don't have to feel like you
make need to solve the problem or make the feelings go away.
You actually need to do less.
And your challenge is to still feel competent even if you do less,
but you will be much more appreciate action.
Um,
I had one of the little thoughts that when we talked about the things for
longevity and the things for,
for deepening the intimacy and all of these things,
which I didn't talk about,
which is people sitting in the morning and having breakfast,
watching outside the window,
listening to music together,
dancing together for a moment.
You know,
the average pop song is 2.3 minutes.
If you just do that,
it doesn't take a long time because sometimes things are so much work to
maintain this intimacy.
It actually is not.
It's 2.3 minutes to listen to some of the most beautiful love songs ever written
and reconnect with that feeling between the two of you.
Okay.
So I hope that I've given you some ideas,
inspirations,
food for thought in the pursuit of your own loving and trading relationships.
I want to add a piece to Kevin Nina's question.
When do you know that the relationship is done?
Kevin and I was talking about the four horsemen of apocalypse that a famous
researcher on the relationships John Gutmann talks about.
And I wanted to,
to expand a little bit on that.
You know,
one is criticism and uh,
okay,
we,
it,
it's quite easy,
right?
It's complaining,
it's picking a,
at the other person.
It's seeing what you do as circumstantial and seeing the other person as
characterological,
right?
Uh,
if,
if you're in a bad mood,
it's because we had a tough day.
But if the other person doesn't act very nice,
these,
because they're actually generally a mean person,
you know,
or a bad tempered person rather than the two may have had a bad day.
Right?
So all the elements that have to do with criticism,
the way that people just know at the other person and just go and circle around
the same grievances over and over again.
That's the piece that he's talking about.
Stonewalling is silent treatment.
It's basically,
you know,
withdrawing,
uh,
removing oneself and letting the other person stand out there and talk to the
walls.
That's another major,
uh,
horsemen of apocalypse.
Defensiveness,
the fact that,
you know,
you can't bring anything up without the other person instantly rejecting
defensive going nature instead of just saying,
yes,
thank you for telling me.
Let me think about this.
Or simply,
uh,
I,
that doesn't feel good,
but,
uh,
you know,
probably I do.
Yes,
I do do that.
You know,
uh,
I don't mean to,
but I do.
Or a or,
or it's an old habit,
bad habit of mine or something that acknowledges that stands accountable,
that doesn't enter the,
yeah,
but you,
you know,
and then says you did worse and then starts to pile up,
and,
and for everything you said,
the other person counters right away with something worse so that they never
have to look at the thing that you said you said.
Yeah.
But yesterday you all of that,
okay.
That defensiveness,
it's a,
it's very rich defensiveness,
but it basically leaves you without the feeling that you ever can bring
something up and that it will be responded to for its own sake.
Um,
and then contempt,
that's the one that I think is the final killer,
um,
for a relationship.
And that went already detailed for you.
They wanted you to have a sense about,
this is for your question actually about the relationship being done,
but also the question that was asked by Alicia asked about how to lessen the
arguments in your,
in your relationship.
So the opposite of these four killers of relationship have to do with how do
people stay connected in the midst of disagreement.
And I think the most,
and this is something I wanted to expand more for,
an easiest question,
is that you really need to know something about arguing in a relationship.
It often has very little to do with the content of the argument itself.
When couplers enter into a vicious cycle and they are reactive and they escalate
and the bigger and the fight,
it doesn't really matter the subject anymore.
At a certain point,
if it's the kids or the car or the money or what they were going to do for
Christmas,
it all is going to sound the same.
And what you're going to hear is that people end up being in an interaction
where they don't feel acknowledged,
they don't feel validated,
they feel dismissed,
they feel that the other person competes with them,
that they are outmaneuvered and it doesn't matter what they talk about.
So there's the real truth about conflict in relationships is that the form
precedes the content.
The way these arguments and fall is one in the same.
If it is this or if it is about Greenpeace in South Korea,
it makes no difference.
It's no longer about the issue itself.
And once you know that,
then you have to go out the form.
And the form is what the people are doing to each other while they say the
things they say.
And what they're doing is this long list.
I've just gone through the opposite of dismissing and disqualifying and
invalidating is acknowledging and recognizing and validating and empathizing.
And that doesn't mean you don't agree.
So there's a very,
very good method developed by Mark Howard Markman,
sorry I,
it's called prep.
Um,
and it's a book fighting for your marriage.
It's actually quite good.
And in prep,
basically they tell you in negative communication,
you pretty much have 10 seconds before you get ready for the rebuttal.
That's about as much as you can listen to something that you Bergner says and
that you disagree with in 10 seconds is three sentences.
So to where you minimize the arguments is by beginning to practice reflective
listening.
It's tedious.
It's annoying,
but it's highly effective.
What I'm hearing you say and you repeat is there more and you repeat and vice
versa,
and then when you talk you do x,
Y,
z statements.
When you do x in situation,
why I feel z when you don't even look up when I walk into the house,
because you're busier to computer the whole time
and I am trying to make a connection with you.
I feel like I don't matter and you don't love me.
Something like that that is very different from you couldn't give a fuck about
me and anytime I come home you on purpose,
pretend that you didn't hear it.
That's an attack from that attack or you're going to get is a defense and the
defense can be a counter attack or stonewalling a or a defensiveness or a
criticism or a or a content that here you have your four horses.
The sentence is broken down in such a way that if I have an experience of what
you do that is not the same as my defining that this is what you do.
It says that when you do this,
I experience it in a certain way and that's my feeling and you can't argue with
the other person's feeling.
You can argue in another person trying to define you and to define your
negatively that Xyz is intensely transformative when people really begin to
practice it.
So that's one way out of the little helper of chronic arguments.
Okay.
Take a few of the questions that I haven't that I haven't spoken about.
How can men effectively handle their sex drive?
Asks The v Weinstock look,
I don't know exactly what you mean by effectively handled their sex drive.
If you're asking,
you know what two men do when they are horny and and,
and they want to have sex but they don't have partners available or they have a
point of a steady partner who is not there at that moment or not interested.
I think one of the things that I would say is this,
sex for men is very much connected to what goes on inside of them.
If they're angry,
if they're happy,
if they're anxious,
if they're depressed,
if they feel good about themselves.
And if they don't,
some men turn to sex to suit themselves when they're anxious,
besides when they feel good.
That's a given.
Some men experienced sex as the one and only language to which they can
experience emotional intimacy.
So men experienced sex as the only language to whom to which they can feel
tender w to soft connected.
Uh,
they won't be the first time that you will hear women describe guys who open up,
who they feel are truly there,
who are really intimate with them on insects because it is the sanction language
for guys to experience but otherwise are often forbidden emotions for men.
So that's for me,
when you ask about effectively handling sex drives,
it has to do with that.
It has to do with being not just monolingual,
having many languages available,
having many ways to act,
to take care of our needs of our feelings and not just one.
That's the effectiveness of sex is to not have it be x.
The only thing available,
uh,
for the rest.
Uh,
I'm not sure that there is a unique way to effectively deal with drives.
But one thing you need to know,
sex is not a drive.
You don't die from not having sex.
You die from not being touched,
but you don't die from not having sex.
It's a motivational system.
It's not a drive that's not the same.
Ebbing is asking what are some of the suggestions and resources that she has for
couples who want to explore having a more monogamish relationships,
not poly,
but more flexible than traditional monogamy,
especially when it comes to navigating boundaries,
emotions and sexual health.
It's a beautiful question.
So first of all,
there's the movie that comes out right now.
How has police movie called monogamish?
Uh,
it's premiering in New York actually this week.
So,
um,
that would be a very nice movie to see together because it really opens up the
conversation.
Um,
and for me the open relationship is less about what people actually do than the
openness of the conversation itself.
Many people don't really want to do as much as they want to do that.
They could if they wanted.
They don't want to feel that they live with the restrictions of the boundaries
and then it's a conversation.
What is it that you miss?
What is it that you feel drawn to?
What would you like to experience?
Do you want to experience it to,
do you want to experience it together?
Do you want me to know about it?
Is it a turnoff for you if I tell you or do you actually not want to know about
it?
And often you'll find you have one of each in a couple.
Is it do you want to be,
is it something that you want that is fleeting,
that is just that if you meet someone you want the possibility of letting
something unfold and see where it takes you.
Is it when you travel because you're often away or is it that you have been with
me since you were 17 and you want to know other partners cause you've never
known others beside me.
It's this whole conversation and not to take it immediately as something is
missing.
I can't give you everything.
I should be everything for you.
If you have any other interest,
it must mean that I'm not enough.
It's really that conversation.
And what you will find is that the couples for whom this is a joint interest,
um,
the conversation itself is often very enlightening,
very vibrant,
and very,
very intimate because the possibility of,
to your partner about your longings for that which takes place outside and need
to have it be recognized and accepted is a deeply intimate conversation.
The,
the,
the recognition of your freedom of your,
of your erotic freedom on which you may not act,
but that it exists even in fantasy,
even in curiosity,
in longing,
in interest,
is profoundly intimate for couples.
And then you talk about,
do we want to do,
I want to know what do we tell each other?
Do we notify in advanced?
We tell after it has happened.
Uh,
what is it that you want to know and understand that you don't have necessarily
a symmetric need.
One of you may want to know more,
one of you doesn't,
one of you likes to share,
one of you doesn't.
You don't have to be one in the same.
And then you come back in you and you examine it works for us.
It doesn't work for us.
It makes brings us closer.
It makes us too nervous.
It now in the end it doesn't,
it's not a good thing for us or not right now because we have young kids and
we're not equal because one of us is not working and we're not equal because one
of us has been sick and we're not,
you know,
by definition they need to be a certain level of,
of equality in the relationship for the conversation to not be a power maneuver,
a boat,
people need to have the same possibilities.
Um,
they may not both want to act on them,
but they need to vote no that they could if they wanted any,
if that's part of the agreement and then you come back and you examine this is,
is this good for us?
This is work.
When I say work,
meaning do we feel enriched by it or do we feel like it's depleting us,
that it's taking away from us that it ultimately now we thought it would be a
good idea but it's not really,
or this has actually opened up things between us that we,
we've had a whole different level of honesty between us,
a whole different level,
depth of communication that never existed before.
We bring back different parts of ourselves.
Um,
the reunions are beautiful.
We make love before we go off to meet someone else.
We only accepted when one of us is traveling.
It's a very rich conversation and it's often many,
many conversations before anybody even act on any of this.
That's how this process goes.
Then you can read some books,
you can retell minnows book open,
you can um,
read sex at dawn.
I mean this and you can talk to other people who actually practice consensual
non monogamy varieties thereof and how it works for them.
You get ideas,
but often people don't tell you that that's what they do because it's so
negatively judged.
So it's not like you can go and ask them how to do,
how do you raise your children?
Because I'm looking for some ideas,
but you will find people who are willing to talk and I have experienced it for
years.
So the,
the practice that it,
that doesn't mean it's what works for you,
but it inspires you.
It gives you what you should be thinking about.
And that's how I would start this thing.
The last question that we'll do.
How do I help people come to terms and come to accept themselves?
You know,
um,
for me self acceptance is really a process of maturation.
It,
Eh,
uh,
I don't expect people in their twenties to easily accept themselves.
So I do put this on a spectrum of time.
But I think the fundamental experience of accepting yourself is that you accept
that you are flow.
You accept,
uh,
the things that are beautiful about you and use begin to feel with I'm good
enough.
I mean,
that's the essence.
It's not unperfect it's,
I'm good enough or I'm flawed and I make mistakes,
but they don't thank me.
I don't feel instantly,
massively embarrassed.
And ashamed about them,
I'm able to look at them and just say,
okay,
I'll do better next time.
I do it differently next time I learned from this.
Um,
it's that process that is self acceptance.
I mean I remember making mistakes and then not sleeping for three weeks at a
time,
you know,
and churning and obsessing about it and replaying it in my head.
Today I do some of these mistakes and I just think,
okay,
I know that mistake and uh,
I don't like it.
It doesn't feel good,
but it doesn't cripple me anymore in the same way.
I think that's the level of self acceptance of said was,
is also knowing what you want and,
and feeling okay about it.
Not uh,
not feeling like you have to continuously justify,
explain,
apologize.
It's a,
it's what I call the healthy sense of entitlement,
not grandiose sense of entitlement.
Self acceptance is self confidence.
Self acceptance is also the ability to live with your lack of confidence in your
insecurities and your uncertainties.
And to say this is an area where I feel deeply insecure and it's part of who I
am.
Um,
I have it all the time.
all of this is self acceptance.
It's a,
your ability to live with your sense of ambivalence,
the things about yourself that you like in that you don't like.
Um,
the things that you feel really good about and the things that you are very
troubled by their ability to integrate those two,
that's the ability to live with ambivalence about oneself is an essential
ingredient of self acceptance.
It's all of that.
And for me,
it's a process of maturation over life.
Um,
this is not something you,
you just one day have.
It grows on you slowly,
physically,
emotionally in terms of lifestyle.
You know,
what you like,
you accepted,
you don't drink,
you don't force yourself anymore to be who you're not.
Uh,
you're okay in Nu skin.
Um,
I often say,
you know,
if I had the,
the confidence of today with the looks of them,
um,
but when,
when I was young,
I didn't have the confidence.
It's a,
it,
it's an interesting thing that has a lot more to do with life experience.
Um,
then with any actual trainings that you're going to have.
But that's my suggestions for self acceptance.
Goodbye.
Thank you very much and I hope we talk again soon and I hope that um,
you can draw from some of these answers and a feed on them for a while until uh,
until the next meal as we say when a pity like,
hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends,
for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one and if you sign
up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many,
many years.
It comes with me everywhere on the telephone in my pocket.
I love audio books and they are one of my favorite ways to pass the time.
More than that,
to indulge myself,
to educate myself with time that would otherwise go to waste in some respects.
What I'm taking walks when I'm cooking,
cleaning up the house on the road for travel,
whatever,
and those in between spaces or as a secondary activity.
I love using audible to help me transform my downtime in a way and it's allowed
me to consume more books,
many more books than I would otherwise.
You can access an unbeatable selection of bestsellers,
mysteries,
thrillers,
and anything you could possibly imagine.
I have two to recommend right off the bat.
One.
Uh,
and they recommended this even for nonfiction purists.
This is a fiction book ready player one by Ernest Cline.
Alright,
that's read by Wil Wheaton ready player one layer in his client.
Check it out.
The reviews are bonkers and this has a cult following.
And then very selfishly on mentioned one that I put together with one of you
guys with actually of listener of the podcast,
who is also a huge fan of Seneca.
So the book is Tao of Seneca Tao Tao of Seneca,
s n,
e,
c,
a subtitle,
practical letters from a stoic master.
And this is effectively an introduction to what I view as the ultimate operating
system for thriving in high stress environments.
That is stoicism.
It's become very popular among top athletic coaches,
CEOs of fast growing companies.
So checking up that is for nonfiction folks who must read or listen to them
fiction Tao of Seneca graphical letters from a stoic master.
And as the listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
you have access to a 30 day trial and your first audio book is free,
so why not go grab one of those ready player one or town of Seneca,
go to audible.com forward slash Tim to start downloading.
Now,
membership includes one free audio book every month,
exclusive sales,
so just 30% off,
all regularly priced audio books.
And unlike streaming,
you own your books once they have been downloaded.
And I like to listen oftentimes when I'm offline,
so you have that benefit as well.
You can't make more time folks just not manufacturing anymore.
It's out of print.
Uh,
you can't make more time,
but you can make the most of it.
It's a turn your travel,
commute,
dog walk,
whatever into something more with a free trial at audible,
audible.com forward slash Tim to learn more and starting now,
this episode is brought to you by zip recruiter.
You may have heard them everywhere.
They're growing like crazy.
They're an innovative platform for doing several things,
but especially improving the hiring process,
making it slick and elegant and easy.
One of the hardest parts of running any business,
growing any business is finding and hiring the right team.
I've seen this firsthand in close to a hundred startups now,
God,
I'm getting old from all over the world at different stages of growth and
nothing can quite drain your resources and cost you time and money like making
mistakes in hiring.
Ziprecruiter developed their own system and their own platform for helping you
to solve two of the biggest problems and bottlenecks for employers posting jobs
easily and then making it even easier to find the best candidates.
Unlike other job sites,
ZipRecruiter does in effect the opposite of what you'd expect.
So they do not depend on candidates finding you there.
Technology finds the right candidate for you and in fact more than 80% of the
jobs posted on ZipRecruiter return a qualified candidate based on your criteria
that you select in just 24 hours.
So no more juggling email.
We're doing hundreds of unqualified candidates.
I've been there,
done that.
Don't recommend it or dealing with calls to the office,
etc. None of that.
Simply screen rate and manage your candidates all in one place on Ziprecruiter's
dashboard and as a listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
actually that ZipRecruiter wants to allow you to start posting jobs and trying
their services for free.
So if you're thinking of hiring somebody,
you need to find me an executive assistant.
You need to find a developer,
whatever it might be to try it out.
Just visit zip recruiter.com/tim and you can experience just how ZipRecruiter
has been used by businesses of all different sizes to find the most qualified
job candidates.
Again,
that's ziprecruiter.com forward slash Tim check it out,
give it a spin.